ABBY CAREY: Hey,
I'm Abby, and I'm
a developer advocate for Google
Cloud Developer Experiences.
NAFIUL ISLAM: And I'm
Nafiul from JetBrains.
And we're going to
walk you through how
to build a Cloud Run service
using a little plugin
in PyCharm called Cloud Code.
ABBY CAREY: Cloud
Code is a plugin
that makes your local
development experience
with Google Cloud Services,
like GKE and Cloud Run,
more streamlined and convenient.
It's supported for
a variety of IDEs,
including PyCharm and IntelliJ.
Nafiul, how can everyone get in
on the PyCharm and Cloud Code
action?
NAFIUL ISLAM: Well, first,
you need PyCharm installed.
Now to install Cloud Code,
head to the marketplace
by clicking Preferences,
then Plugins,
and search for Cloud Code.
You might be prompted
to restart PyCharm.
Once that's done, Cloud
Code should be ready.
You'll need Docker installed
and running in the background
to use Cloud Code.
While Cloud Code
automatically installs
command-line dependencies,
like the Cloud SDK, for you,
you might need to
manually install it
if you have certain permissions
blocking the install.
Later in this
video, I'll show you
how to add a Cloud SQL database
connection to both your Cloud
Run service and
PyCharm's database panel.
For that step, you'll need
to install Cloud SQL Proxy.
Check the description for
more info on how to do this.
Abby, want to show how to
get started with a Cloud Run
sample?
ABBY CAREY: Sure thing.
Once you install
Cloud Code, you'll
notice some new UI in PyCharm.
To the right, there are
Cloud Code-specific panels
that align with different
Google Cloud flows.
We'll be focusing on Cloud Run,
so I'll open Cloud Code's Cloud
Run panel.
Here, you can view your
deployed Cloud Run services
and right click them
to view their URLs.
Getting started with Cloud Run
has a slight learning curve
if you choose to build
your image with Docker.
With Cloud Code, you can
create a new Cloud Run
project that comes with
a handy Dockerfile,
or build with
buildpacks instead.
To create a new project,
select New Project,
go over to Cloud Code, Cloud
Run, and then give it a name.
You can then choose
between Flask or Django
for your project.
We're going to choose
Flask and hit Create.
Now that the sample
is loaded, you
have a boilerplate
project for Flask.
It's a simple Hello
World service,
and here's that
Dockerfile I mentioned.
To run a Cloud Run
service locally,
Cloud Code comes packaged
with a Cloud Run emulator.
When you run your service
locally in the emulator,
you get to test
and debug your code
in a production-like
environment.
This sample's emulator
is already configured,
but what if you wanted to
add environment variables
or connect this service
to a Cloud SQL database?
You can edit your configuration,
and under Advanced Revision
Settings, you can update your
service's CPU allocation,
Environment Variables, and
specify Cloud SQL database
Connections.
To connect your Cloud Run
service to a Cloud SQL
database, just put your
instance connection name here
and you're good to go.
In a minute, Nafiul
will walk through how
to connect PyCharm to
a Cloud SQL database
to make working with
databases easier.
You can also specify
a Service Account,
which is very important for
authenticating your Cloud Run
service with Google Cloud APIs.
And towards the bottom
of my run configuration,
I can pick my builder.
I'll stick with
using my Dockerfile,
but if I didn't have one,
I could select Buildpacks,
which analyzes your
application structure
and determines the best
way to containerize it.
But everything is looking good.
Now I can either debug or run
my service in the emulator.
I'm only going to run this
service in this video.
But if I were to debug
this, it would look exactly
like the PyCharm debugging
experience you're used to.
All right, now let's run this.
PyCharm is now running
the application locally.
The first time you
spin up the emulator
can take a couple minutes, but
future runs are much faster.
Now we got a local URL, so
let's try clicking on it.
And boom, your app
is hosted locally
in the Cloud Run
emulator and logs
are displayed in the output.
This service is ready
to deploy to Cloud Run.
But before we do
that, though, Nafiul,
could you talk about
PyCharm's database support?
NAFIUL ISLAM: Yeah.
PyCharm Pro comes with
integrated database tools.
PyCharm's Databases panel
allows you to seamlessly check
your Cloud SQL database.
This lets you check to see if
your code is making the desired
changes in your database.
To connect to a Cloud SQL
database from PyCharm,
you'll need to install
and run the Cloud SQL
Proxy from a terminal.
Then all we need
to do is give it
the name of the instance
we want to connect to
and the port we want to
forward that connection to.
This creates a proxy to
our localhost on that port.
After doing this, we can
head into our Databases tab
and add a database.
In this case, I'm
adding Postgres.
I've setup a username and
password, so I'll put that in.
Now I'll test the connection.
In general, it's always good to
check that your connection is
working with the configurations
and credentials you've
given it.
Once we have that
setup, we can see
what schemas are
available to us and what
tables are available in
that particular schema.
That's the quick and easy way
to work with Cloud SQL databases
from PyCharm.
Now I think it's time
to deploy our service.
ABBY CAREY: To
deploy your service,
you now need to edit the
Deploy Configurations
and give it a Google
Cloud project.
From here, you can set
extra configurations,
like we did for the emulator.
Everything seems to be in order.
I'm building my image
locally with Docker,
but you can also build in
the Cloud with Cloud Build.
Because we're building
this from a Dockerfile,
we can hit Apply and then OK.
Now we can press that green
Play button and run this.
This tells PyCharm
to start deploying.
Cloud Code is now building and
pushing my container image.
And once that's complete,
we get a service
URL and my-first-service
appears in the Cloud Run panel.
We also get a handy link to the
logs of my deployed service.
And congratulations,
your service
is now running on Google Cloud.
Anyone can access it.
That was a look at getting
started with Cloud Run using
PyCharm and Cloud Code.
I encourage you to install
Cloud Code from your IDE's
marketplace, and if
you have any questions,
you can reach out to us
on our Slack channel.
NAFIUL ISLAM: Thank you
so much for watching.
If you want to learn more
about how to use PyCharm,
check out our YouTube channel.
We're constantly
putting out new videos
that will teach you
how to use PyCharm
and also how we make PyCharm.